Brady is with us in Des Moines Iowa
hi Brady welcome to the Dave Ramsey show
I think with you certainly how can I
help my wife and I are on baby steps we
we completed a debt free journey and all
last year came down as if every scream
with you last summer this is so we're
kind of looking process of looking at
houses we've got the 10% minimum you
suggest saved up and continuing the bill
that as we look as I started looking for
houses right now we're kind of noticing
that that number we set for our 15 for
sure no more than your 25% excuse me
take-home pay it seems like they're
always something major that is a year or
two away from you know look four to five
five six thousand dollars a client
there's all that sort of thing but it
seems like when we go if we were to go
you know that twenty eight twenty nine
percent of the take home pay more than
those issues and you're gonna get
building more move-in ready house what
would you suggest doing in that term I
think you need to keep looking okay you
haven't found the house you just found
the rationalization and here's the thing
the way you ask yourself the question is
not what Dave Ramsey would do because
who gives a rip really at the end of the
day but the question you ask yourself is
what is going to cause us to win long
term financially and what happens
inevitably to me and to you when we
start looking at houses and we start
looking at cars we always see the ones
that are nicer we always do I was I was
in Florida on a trip for fun and Sharon
and I were considering buying a Beach
condo we've now decided not to thank you
Jesus but we were looking at it you know
a vacation home right
so we start looking at one price but
before we know it we've got the money
but before we know it we've crept up
almost 50 percent
because guess what those that were 50%
more expensive we're a lot freaking
nicer you know it's just a normal human
thing to go oh I could get that car but
I could get that car you know it's a
normal human thing to let you know it's
a creep it's a scope creep kind of thing
that happens to us and so I would resist
that because I think it's a good
emotional spiritual relational exercise
to resist that and I'll give you another
example okay of just a way to think
about it you do what you want to do at
the other day okay but I think if you'll
stick to your guns five years from now
ten years from now you'll be glad you
did even if you put a roof on something
or even if you bought a dishwasher
you're gonna be glad you did because
you're gonna be moving towards your
goals much more rapidly but here's
another thing once I decided and Sharon
decided we no longer borrow money for
anything ever
I'm not suggesting that with you I'm
okay with your 15 year fixed okay you
know that you know the program you've
been working the program but I'm just
saying once we had this new guideline in
your case it's 15 years no more and a
fourth your take-home pay fixed right in
my case it was I can't buy it if I don't
have the money period once we have that
guideline it did two very good things
for us
number one it ruled out a bunch of stuff
we just can't do that I just don't have
the money I just can't do that on the
money the second thing is if it was
something I was trying to do and I
thought I could almost do it I had to
just kind of get creative and figure out
a way to pull it off without borrowing
money to pull it off
I had to negotiate them down I had to
option the thing and then come back
later and buy it when I could get the
cash together I've done that on real
estate deals that I'm in the money to
close on it right now but I will have in
six months and so I'd give them some
money for an option I just get creative
to where I still get the deal done but I
don't have to violate my guideline my
boundary that I put in place it made me
become a little bit more creative and it
may
me learn to say no and those are the two
things I would put on you if four do you
know it's a different guideline it's not
that that free guideline but is the
15-year fixed-rate where the payments no
more than a fourth your take-home pay we
all get scope creep we all creep up the
scope of what we're looking at if it's a
dress or a purse or a suit of clothes or
a pair of shoes it's it's almost
immeasurable if it's a house or a car
you feel it and see it because the
purchase is so much larger